using face-to-face networking to grow
your business so I got a great question
from one of my patreon supporters love
you guys
dan winegar who wrote in to ask me hi
Evan I'd love to see a video on using
face to face networking to grow your
business for me this is a bit of a
tricky one and I think number one you
have to figure out what style best fits
your personality and so if you are the
type of person who is outgoing energetic
loves talking to people type A
personality then you need to be all over
face to face networking you gotta be
going to networking groups and we go to
conferences and trade shows and being
out meeting people you know you'll
you'll have a lot of great business
success and you'll also be happier
because that's what you'd like to do you
need to be surrounded by people for
myself I'm not that type a personality
when I go to networking events when I go
to conferences I don't go to conferences
anymore unless I'm speaking at them you
know I'm not the guy who's gonna go up
to every booth and say hey I'm Evan
here's what I do is there way to work
together I don't talk to the guy next
mini airplane I'm I don't know I'm kind
of shy and kind of introverted they may
not come across in the videos but I am
and so for me for my business at takeoff
I had to find another way to stand
because if it was gonna rely on me doing
sales calls and and going to these
networking events and conferences to
attend it wouldn't work because it
doesn't fit my personality Wow so
instead I focus more on thought
leadership and I'm the guy who speaks at
the conferences and as a result people
come up to me and make connections and
I'm happy to talk to people I'm just not
the initiator usually
and so that's worked out for my style
very well so I think first of all if
you're thinking about using networking
in your business it's figuring out what
is your personality style do you like
talking to people and do like being
around people a lot or not there's no
right or wrong answer it's just figuring
out your personality style because being
truthful with yourself will help you
devise a strategy that works for you
number two is when you're networking you
want to network with the right people
right you want to make sure that the
people who you're connecting to are your
target audience or know your target
audience you know if your real estate
agent or if you're an insurance
salesperson and your network is
everybody you know you can sell to
anybody then that's what you should be
doing right you're out meeting everybody
because they can all be potential
customers for you if your target
audience is this is a specific group of
people specific industry then you wanted
network strategically you know maybe
joining the networking group won't be
the right fit for you because you need
really targeted referrals so make sure
when you're networking you're networking
with the right group of people my third
thought is when you have the chance meet
people face to face you get so much more
done and you create such a strong
personal bond when you can meet somebody
face to face instead of just over the
phone or just by email just over social
media it's amazing what it can do to
create a relationship you know it's only
one time for my business most of it is
done internationally and I'm based in
Toronto Canada but most of my clients
are an American
and so my deals are done to put over the
phone an email but whenever I get the
chance if somebody's visiting here from
work with a local client I like to go
meet them face to face because it builds
their relationship and builds trust and
other opportunities come out of it
beyond just this one set thing that
we're supposed to do so those are my
thoughts on networking frontrunners it
can be a huge boost for your business if
you do it properly and a quick story on
Dan so Dan was one who asked me about
this video then is a great networker and
Dan has been a fan of my social media
channels for a while as competent and
been active and involved and
he actually invited me to come and speak
is event that his company was putting on
he works with chemical home video
studios he's a franchisee and he invited
me to come speak and he picked me up
from the airport and he hung out with me
on the first night we went for dinner
and you know it was always just a
resource and being super helpful and
even afterwards now he's keeping me up
to date with what he's doing and sending
in videos and supporting him or my
staffers dannion is just a master
networker and if you guys want to learn
more about that workday maybe maybe I'll
have to have Dan on and we'll do a
Google+ Hangout and share some tips and
strategies if you guys are interested in
that leave in the comments below and
we'll make that happen
by god those are my initial thoughts and
networking for those of you watching if
you like this video you can subscribe to
the channel you can support me by
clicking on the link in description and
leave a comment below let me don't you
think your comments mean a lot to me and
really appreciate thank you ll see you
see